my name is moccasin Ogawa I'm an alkene
AMA student activist I'm participating
in the sit-in protest at Camp Schwab
Pinnacle to stop the new construction of
US base the new base will destroy the
ocean life I feel really angry
as youth we should raise our voice and
to be involved more in activities
because it's our future
the Japan central government is keep
breaking the promise because they
promise to close up Tenma base in the
first place in 1996 and it's they're
still in 2015
the Okinawans don't feel like our voices
are hard they're just pushing us a new
base and more and more bases it sound
fair so I don't I don't like it I think
it's definitely occupation why are there
so many US bases on this island in Japan
the Battle of Okinawa was one of the
bloodiest Pacific combats